I got bad news for jenz if we are below
uh maybe not so JZ but J Alpha if we're
below a replacement rate reproduction
that means that there will be more
Millennials than gen Z more Millennials
than gen Alpha that means that the
interests of the economy will favor the
larger Generations so so uh typically
what you see is a lot of companies will
try to B you know they try to get woke
because they're like we got to be hip
with the kids when I worked for Fusion
that was that was the thing they were
like look we're targeting young people
they're most they're more Progressive so
that's what we're going to do and boy
were they wrong that was not what the
data was showing and they imploded
because of it but they didn't actually
care or believe in any of these things
they just thought we got to go where the
kids are uh Shane Smith of Vice he's
like in his mid-30s when Vice is is uh
uh is is starting to take off he's in
his mid-40s when it really takes off and
he's making content that was targeting
people in their 20s that was the
mentality that a lot of these big
companies had that's not that's not
going to be the case you're going to
launch a company and you're going to say
what's what's the biggest market share
we can get and they're going to say well
we got you know 75 million genz we got
50 million gen Alpha we got 100 million
Millennials we'll screw it go for the
Millennials what about Gen X well I'm
saying like Gen X Gen X is going to be
out of at this at this point when when
Gen Alpha is in the marketplace Gen X is
phased out yeah so I'm talking about gen
Alpha in their late teens and into their
20s Millennials are going to be in their
late 50s and they're going to be exiting
Gen X is already going to be out in the
in retirement less of a consideration in
terms of of big ad spends but this means
that Millennials are going to
continually hold a disproportionate
amount of Market power because of the
size of the generation true so I'm not
I'm not as concerned with seeing a bunch
of crackpot young kids cuz the
likelihood what I what I see being a
what may happen
is as as the market seeks to Pander to
the larger block of of of the market
share these kids are going to have to
adhere and change to fit the mold of
what Millennials want and and not the
other way around right so I think one of
the reasons adults want to be kids you
know like that Abe Simpson meme they I
used to be with it and they changed what
it was and Homer is like that'll never
happen to me man it's because you're
watching TV and you are watching what
you perceive as social acceptance what
does everyone love they love the rockar
I want to be like the Rockstar only
thing is Rockstar is now 20 years
younger than you so you get those
midlife crises where it's like I'm hip I
can be cool what if cool was just what
you were what if the dad jeans and
Rolling Stones never faded out of you
know pop culture uh out out of the
spotlight I don't I think there's going
to be pockets of Fame and personality
among young people obviously because of
their peer groups but if the money is if
if you're going to make $100 million by
doing a Fallout Boy show or how about
this you know the When We Were Young
tour mhm if they make more money doing
that then what's going to happen is
where's the ad spend going to be big
marketing companies going to be like
look this gen Z thing is good but we can
maybe make $20 million but this When We
Were Young Thing these people got money
and there's more of them you could argue
that uh back in the day but hold on
older people always had more money yes
and they had kids and they that money on
their kids and now Millennials don't
have kids and they're spending the money
on themselves so it's going to get real
interesting real soon yeah I think
you're really cultivating towards the
Millennials I found GI Z really
interesting and I can't tell if this is
just sort of a bias view through the
lens of social media but um that seems
like they are really burning through
every generational fashion trend you'll
get these enclaves of girls who really
into 70s stuff or really into the early
2000s or like '90s grunge core was very
popular for a second during Co and then
it kind of went away I mean they are
searching for generational identity and
I don't think they are creating one for
themselves they have language and they
have social media but social media isn't
enough to actually have generational
culture when I was a kid a Nirvana shirt
was a band that was playing music at the
time and then you know not for a time
after that in late 90s but like people
would have the holes in their jeans in
the Nirvana shirt when Nirvana was
releasing music it's really funny to see
that Viral Tik Tok where that like
18-year-old girl she's wearing a Devana
shirt she's like I don't even know what
this is it's just like it's at Hot Topic
and everyone wears it yeah but then some
Millennial mom also buys them for her
like Toddlers and then chase them around
being like name three songs I what I am
telling you is not predictive it is
descriptive go to the mall yo I I I I go
to the mall and Hot Topics got Nightmare
Before Christmas what year did that
movie come out 1993 or something yeah
and and and I see Jen I see Jen Alpha
gen Z wearing like Before Christmas
stuff and I'm like they don't have their
own like you were saying generational
identity we do night before Christmas
that was Millennial and I think it's
because they have to spend all their
time on I'm Gen X how old are
you oh 10 well you said your Gen X you
got answer I'm I'm a zillennial so I'm
in
between um but so but so you were you
were old enough to be part of the people
who are wearing the Jack Skellington
shirts and stuff it's it's crazy now to
see young people making videos where
they're wearing Nirvana and and
Nightmare for Christmas now don't get me
wrong when I was growing up I also had
like my my mom had we had a bunch of
Zeppelin shirts Grand Funk Railroad
whatever Doobie Brothers I don't know I
know what that stuff was ' 80s music but
it's different it's be you go to the
mall and it's not modern new stuff when
I was a kid went to the mall Night
Before Christmas was new you went to Hot
Topic and it was like here's new things
now I go in it's bleach and naroto and
I'm like dude that was 20 years ago it's
St I don't even know cre stall which I
think is
much I feel like it's Nostalgia is like
a drug of complacency and a lot of
people like a lot of Millennials and
where people our age even older and
younger they they just want to live like
Tim saying as uh adult babies so they
are dressing themselves like they did
when they were babies I think that
explains older people but for Gen Z they
should be serving up something that they
can replace right and they're not and I
think some of that and this is just my
maybe touch grass moment here but I
think some of it is because they spend
so much time online looking for what's
trendy instead of going out and
even wor drug that's regurgitated
there's no nucleus no there's not no and
to be fair Co wrecked some of it for the
for Gen Z cu the leaders of gen Z all
had to then go home and then spend more
time on the internet and not with each
other they're just like Googling so
that's why Y2K took off wearing y 2K
because that was then when they were
kids and look at us like retro I learned
this like jenzy paw when you when you
make a video you know how sometimes
they're like hi the jensy Paw hi like
there's so many rules yeah
or they put text really small on videos
that's something that
Millennials but it's to make you look at
the thing for longer right I mean
they're crazy but it's all driven by
social media in a way that no generation
has been 1990 was the LA the '90s were
the last decade I love the90s were Peak
human existence it was the last itak
America there's younger people listening
who like those old tell me about the 9s
guys Paris Elon man juy Couture
everybody can argue about the generation
they like and for Millennials and gen
xers who had like a formative years in
the '90s are going to say the '90s were
great the ' 80s were kind of weird the
70s had their had their time the 60s had
their time but these are discernable
Generations or decades you look at
Styles someone can show you a picture of
a living room and you'll be like oh that
was the 50s someone can show you the
picture of a diner and be like that's
70s someone can show you a picture of a
guy just a guy wearing clothes and would
be like that was the80s he's wearing
like neon leopard print hot pants and
you're like we know when that was
feathery hair and the 9s Y and then the
2000s happened and there are some things
like uh how about I I say some things
because skinny jeans of ballet flats man
no it started to break apart yeah uh so
uh wearing a long sleeve shirt with a
short sleeve shirt over it but that only
was in certain areas of of the
millennial generation yeah for sure I
wonder if it's because of the internet
but uh we were uh we downstairs hanging
out in the green before the show and I'm
like I tell the the TV to play top songs
from the 80s and everybody knows the
songs and it's like shout comes on and
oh of course Tears for Fears and I'm
like just put on tears fors came up here
I was like I was like '90s it was like
Audio Slave I think you were playing uh
what were we playing no no no I was
playing uh it to's posum Kingdom oh nice
and uh do you wna
die and so uh I'm driving in my car and
we put on '90s playlist every song that
come comes on we're like man I know this
song and then I was like well we've done
' 80s we've done' 70s cuz the 70s you
got a bunch of hits you know of course
and then I uh uh I I said put on hits
from the 2000s I knew none of it well
2000s Britney Spears
in um I don't know who else but wasn't
that late 90s J Rule early into the
early 2000s yeah Nelly Nelly it was much
more one was Usher big he was around for
a minute be big again cuz the halftime
show there's no stopping Usher I think
it's the internet Creed Jack pic
Creed 9s for sure I think it's because
of the internet and what happened was
the reason we all knew these songs is
because there was only like five places
to get the songs yes but I noticed this
when I was younger and I started getting
really angry it's the 2000s I'm a
teenager and q101 the radio station in
Chicago was only playing stun Pilots oh
no no krock is LA right yeah it was
playing Stone Pilots basically no matter
what you do you get stone pilots and you
get Pearl Jam and I'm like dude that
song is like 12 years old and then I
remember coming back like a few years a
few years ago and I was like wow they're
playing music from 30 years ago yeah
that's crazy and it's like rock
alternative rock and I'm like yes it's
you're not it's an oldie station dude
when I was a kid we had the oldie
station old these 104.3 and they it's
the '90s and they' play songs from the
50s and 60s mhm so now if you're playing
music from the 99s and the ' 80s like
you're oldies dude did you listen to
96.3 in Chicago oh B96 B96 of course oh
B96 man that was my see I feel like I
didn't really grow up listening to the
radio and so I'm feel like I missed all
kinds of mus listen to radio the way
here I still like the radio oh see I
just listen to NPR all the time because
I'm oh yeah for sure I'm I'm why do you
torture yourself the thing is it's good
to see what other people are doing and
how they're presenting things and at the
time I was when I when I've got my
license because I'm a nerd uh when I got
my driver's license at 16 or whatever I
would drive around listening to This
American Life which I thought was such
an
interesting great show and then I tried
to listen to it as a podcast in podcast
War recently and it was just so
different and I feel like in some ways
if you were you know a music connoisseur
in the 90s and ' 80s and you're like
this is really good music any Recreation
cuz obviously your favorite bands will
have their moment and die down the the
the ones that come after them are not
good enough to to feel like they're
carrying on the tradition and so in some
ways these traditions of you know I
think this was like big band music they
just die partially because they go out
of fashion but also because there isn't
anyone who's able to carry on the torch
effectively yeah I I still love I think
radio is great and like when I travel so
much I'm driving so much I like
listening to radio in different areas to
see like what they're listening to and
St reg radio how you find oh dude Road
road trips were so fun when like you'd
start to lose a radio station and then
you try and look for the next one and
then all of a sudden it's like you start
hearing both at the same time and then
you know we're driving and I'm and I'm
hearing like blink2 on the radio what's
My Age Again and then it's
like well I just got back I'm like whoa
this is you're seeing a cross-section of
culture that was my experience uh when I
first started coming down to West
Virginia during 2020 because there's
nothing to do so I had a lot of driving
around and I was with someone and we got
like four stations back to back that
were all just like very typical what I
would call Pop Punk and this friend like
turned to me and he was like West
Virginia where pop punk never died 101.5
baby it's so funny because there are I
mean in some ways it makes me what I
talk a little bit about on the show
about regionalism and how there is
regional culture in America which is
largely due to foundational immigration
and how we do lose it especially as the
internet becomes more popular but maybe
the radio is what keeps Regional local
culture alive it so right uh we lost
Regional addiction because of Television
because of national television
everyone's trying to look if I'm going
appeal to the entire country we've got
you got to lose the accent or whatever
and I think with the internet you you've
basically taken away we you've reversed
this so now you've got all of these
different subcultures to the point where
some of them are getting really really
weird really weird and creepy people
dressing up like animals doing weird
things yeah but like if so back in the
day we we want people who do nasty gross
things to keep it to themselves yeah the
the the the weird costumes they wear and
they go out in public there's a viral
video of a guy just like a baby in a a
diaper going out and chugging on a
bottle and filming other people and then
talking about how it's getting him off
I'm like we want people like that not to
be able to post these things and like
you that guy would never be on TV no if
so most people got their culture from
very few sources so everybody recognized
something and that builds uh it it
builds a a connection when um when
what's the song Sweet Caroline what's
the name of song it's got not the name
song that's everybody knows it and they
play at the baseball stadium everyone
goes what
about yeah so so I'm I'm at uh we we're
we're at a pool hall I put on a bunch of
music going back from like the 70s till
now and sure enough when I put on
Bohemian rap city the entire bar starts
singing and then someone was like who
did it and like yeah and we're all
singing Bohemian rap C it was fun and
then I put on a few other uh uh you know
hits or whatever and you've got people
sporadically singing then I put on
modern rock and everyone just Tunes out
nobody knows what it is yep yeah modern
is in like right now or yeah yeah like
mus music no like 2010s rock songs and
stuff things that I enjoy I think the
only forance people would know and it
would depend on what age group is at the
bar are some of the really big hits that
were like popular viral Dance videos
during during 2020 especially but not
even not even Taylor Swift people are
singing yeah that's you just listen you
really reflect on the philosophy
there but like every there there's like
uh what What's like everybody knows um
ma Mr bright side with the Killers Mr
brght side that's a big there stuff
nobody sings that well yeah course
that's the difference when when I'm at
prayer some people are like I I I I hate
Mr bright side it's I just can't stand
that song yeah yeah same not I only know
people who sing to it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net